once these Ghanaian fishermen have
landed their catch they don't have much
time in the tropical heat here fish run
very quickly without access to
electricity that can't be kept cool
outside the country's main cities
there's hardly any available power to
run things like refrigerators thousands
of kilometers away in Germany Pike F
extendo and wants to change that he's n
trades manager for Africa n trade makes
compact biomass power plants they're
small enough to transport in a container
so they can supply electricity to
communities in remote locations the post
is called pyrolysis so we heat up
biomass up 2200 degrees in an
oxygen-free environment so in this
reactor the biomass converts to gaseous
carbon monoxide and hydrogen and
therefore we have a very clean gas that
we can generate electricity from in
Africa millions of tons of food every
year spoiled before reaching the market
on average 17 percent of annual corn
yields go bad if they could be preserved
it would boost farming families incomes
Ghanaian businessman Kadampa fo is
visiting n trade he's gathering
information about the many power plants
on behalf of other Ghanaian companies we
like this because this is of great is
independent solutions you can take it to
their communities to the villages to the
farmers and they also if you look at the
inputs these are waste products from
agriculture you can also be waste
product from households and these are
quite cheap to combine plants like these
can cost up to 100,000 euros depending
on output n trade plans to set up the
generators then operate and maintain
them using data links this will allow
technicians in Germany to address any
system problems off site while on-site
trained staff can carry out any physical
repairs basically it's about setting up
an energy
his company and making sure that all the
necessary necessary knowledge is there
to run small energy service company this
business model I believe is is from from
experience I can say that this is really
important and crucial that you have
action economical interest to to operate
and run the system over time Cottam
boffo says he likes the idea and he'll
be recommending it to his Ghanaian
partners if they agree the first n trade
plant could soon be up and running in
Africa then farmers will be able to make
a profit from their harvest waste and
also have cheaper energy for their homes